i i think that's what we have in terms
of practicalities
so welcome to the
april 27 installation of
the beyond satisfiability uh seminar
series
um so the um goal of this seminar series
is to go beyond sat go beyond the np
and for some people you know mp is not
enough they want to solve all of p space
and you want to do quantified boolean
formula solving or qbf solving and today
um florian lonsing from stanford and
martinez from
johannes kepler university lenz will
tell us about the secrets of qbf solving
so this will be
uh if i understood correctly a kind of
tutorialish talk in two parts so florian
will
guide us before the break and then after
roughly an hour maybe we have a break
and then martina continues
something like that yes so victoria
further ado please thank you jacob for
the
introduction um yeah as jacob
mentioned we are going to give you an
overview
of qbf solving today and by doing that
we aim to address
one of the main questions of this
workshop um
that is how can we generalize
efficient satisfiability methods
to problem domains that are beyond np
and in particular
uh we are targeting the p space uh
domain here so uh qf solving is
p space complete it's the canonical
problem in that class
and being that it is a natural candidate
for
effectively encoding problems from that
class or from any class in the
polynomial hierarchy
so we're going to give you an overview
over the main
two of the main solving paradigms
for qbf but before that let's have a
look at some
context in general we are interested in
applying
logic based methods to solve hard
combinatorial problems for instance
so on this chart you can see an abstract
workflow
that we typically apply to solve such
problems
so given some some instance of a problem
we would first encode that problem
in some logic this could be
propositional logic
qbf or first order logic for instance
and then this is an optional step we
apply
pre-processing in order to remove
redundancy for instance
or to make sure that the the encoding
has
a certain properties we want it to have
in the next step we apply solving so we
apply a theorem prover or a set solver
qbf solver to solve our encoding
and ideally the solver provides us
either with a proof
that the instance is unsatisfiable or
with a model
showing us that it is satisfiable so the
model is typically
an assignment to the set of variables
and given that model we can then
map the model back to a solution to the
original problem
which gives us then a solution to the
original problem that we were interested
in
solving so that's a very abstract flow
which applies to
logics in general in particular
it has been shown in the past 20 years
that this workflow is very effective in
the context of propositional logic
so there we have methods to efficiently
encode problems to remove redundancy
this is also done in a more dynamic way
in
in processing for instance in cdcl
solvers
this has been shown to be very effective
in practice
also there have has been a tremendous
improvement in
heuristics combined with low level
optimizations
such as clever memory layouts and
related techniques it is also important
to have efficient and reliable proof
checking
in order to increase reliability of the
results that we obtained from that
workflow
and just to give you a very prominent
example
there was a famous combinatorial problem
the boolean perfectly and triples
problem which was solved
using set-based techniques we take this
example and in general
uh the success story of set uh as an
um as a motivation to actually obtain
um a similar success story in the field
of qbf solving so that's
that's what we are aiming at we want to
establish qbf solving
as a general technique to solve p space
problems
and beyond
so in this talk we focus on quantified
boolean formulas
this is an extension of propositional
logic
where we have existential and universal
quantification over the propositional
variables
the presence of quantification renders
the satisfiability problem
p space complete which is in contrast to
the np
completeness of propositional
satisfiability
so under the typical assumption that np
does not equal p space
as a consequence we have that qbf
checking is
harder on the other hand we can expect
that
the problem encodings in qbf are
exponentially more succinct than
propositional encodings
so in this talk um we will be focusing
on
qbfs in prenex conjunctive normal form
as shown on the slide here
these formulas consist of a quantifier
prefix
and a propositional cnf
in terms of semantics qbf can be
characterized
by assignment trees this is in contrast
to propositional logic
in propositional logic a model is just
a single assignment to the variables
which satisfies the formulas
whereas in qbf we have to actually
find a satisfying assignment tree so
let's have a look
at the example shown here on the slides
the formula shown here is encodes the
equivalence of
x and y under the prefix for all x
exists y so this is a
satisfiable or true formula because
whenever we set x to false
we can also set the existential variable
y
to false and thereby satisfy the
proposition at c and f
and similarly for the variable
assignments where we set the variables
to true
what we also can see here is a
dependency of the existential variable y
on the universal variable x so whenever
the universal variable x is set to false
the universal sorry the existential
variable has
to be set with respect
to the current valuation of the
universal variable
this is also often presented as a
two-person
a two-player game actually where the
universal player controls the universal
variables
and aims to falsify the cnf whereas the
existential player
who controls the existential variables
tries to satisfy the cnf
and the existential player in this
example has to respond
with a variable assignment um
to whatever assignment the universal
player has made before
there is a similar concept of assignment
trees for
unsatisfiable or false formulas which
represent counter models of false qbfs
so this is exactly the same cnf but here
we have flipped
the ordering of the variables now the
prefix is
there exists a y such that for all x the
c and f is true
and this is no longer the case because
if we fix the value of the existential
variable
then the universal player has always the
opportunity to falsify the cnf
and this assignment tree actually
witnesses that
for whatever value of the existential
player there is a way to falsify
the cnf
another way that's often used to
represent qbf semantics
which is closely related to assignment
trees and the
two-player game semantics is the
semantics in terms of colon functions
this colon function is
a function related to the existential
variables
of the formula which tells us
essentially how the existential player
has to respond
um when given um a current move
of the universal player so in this
example f sub y
is this column function that represents
the assignments of the existential
player when given
x which is the assignment of the current
assignments of the universal player so
this is an equivalent way
of thinking about the qbf semantics now
for false qbfs we have a
a related concept called abroad
functions
which is dual abroad functions represent
in this case f sub x is there a draw
function for the universal player
and it tells us how to respond to a
given
move of the existential player y in this
case
uh one important syntactic concept um
that will be that we are interested in
is the number of quantifier alternations
in aprenex cnf
uh a given prenux cnf has a sequence of
quantifier blocks qi bi where qi is a
quantifier and
bi is a set of propositional variables
so
in this example shown here the first
block consists of
two variables x1 and x2 second block
of u1 u2 and so forth
this sequence of blocks is linearly
ordered it introduces
a total ordering on the variables
where blocks which come first are
considered to be smaller than
later blocks in the sequence we assume
that
adjacent blocks have a different
quantifier type so qi
is different from q i plus one and under
this assumption
um a qbf with a pc and f with n
quantifier blocks has
n minus one quantifier alternations
and this is actually useful for
theoretical considerations
because the satisfiability problem at
the complexity of the problem is
closely related to the polynomial
hierarchy
which is a theoretical framework to
describe
the complexity of problems beyond the
class and p
an important theoretical result in that
framework shows that
given a pcnf with k alternations
their respective satisfiability problem
is located
um at level k plus one in the polynomial
hierarchy
where uh the first the type of the first
quantifier
actually tells us whether it's sigma k
plus one complete or
for the universal quantifier whether
it's p
k plus one complete
uh given this characterization we can
actually have a look
at the polynomial hierarchy and identify
um
a set of useful and interesting problems
in practice so at the first level
we have the classes np and co np which
corresponds to
propositional logic satisfiability and
validity checking
and if we go higher to higher levels we
find interesting problems like
mus membership testing of clauses so
this is minimal unsatisfiable subsets
of cnfs there are a couple of problems
related to planning
answer set programming abstract
argumentation and so forth so this is
just to give you
um an idea of the variety of problems
that we can
that we can work on here finally
and the the further up we move we reach
the class
of p space eventually this is a class of
problems where
the number of uh quantifier alternations
depends on the problem instance so
that's a parameter here
and um one one um prominent example
in this class is uh model checking of
linear time
temporary logics for instance there are
also a couple of
automata related problems like language
inclusion checking for non-deterministic
finite automata
and many two-player games
that are p-space complete so
there's lots of applications
that are amenable to qbf related
techniques
of course we mentioned that already
the hardness of qbf comes at the cost so
it's
p space is deemed harder than np but
also offers opportunities in terms of
having more compact encodings
compared to propositional logic and
there is even
if we move higher up in the complexity
hierarchy
there is a an extension of a
generalization of quantified boolean
formulas which is called dependency qbfs
um where the satisfiability problem is
nx time complete so it's even harder
than p space
presumably but this would offer
additional exponential savings in terms
of encoding sizes
so so this this is what we get in terms
of opportunities
now um we move closer to the topic of
our talk today
uh qbf solving when we compare this to
the history of set solving then we find
that
qbf solving is actually a young field of
research compared to set
said started in the 1960s with dpl
whereas qbf started essentially in the
late 90s we have
a variant of dpl for qbf which was
published in
1998 so it's bit more than 20 years ago
and this was later extended to class
learning this is
essentially a variant of cdcl for qbf
and at the same time expansion based
approaches were published and these are
the two topics actually
where we are going to focus on in in the
talk today
in the past 20 years there has been an
increased interest in qbf solving so not
only on the practical side but
in particular in terms of proof systems
so we have a much better understanding
now how
uh to characterize the approaches that
were implemented in early solvers
and we also know new avenues how to
improve
existing approaches in terms of
making use of knowledge improve
complexity
for instance it is now uh well known
that
clause learning a cdcl and expansion are
orthogonal
so each of these approaches have
their own strengths and weaknesses
another important line of research is
qbf solving based on counterexample
guided abstraction refinement this is
the
the well-known seeger approach that came
up in the domain of model checking
let me make a quick announcement here
martina and i
are involved in the organization of
the qbf workshop which is affiliated at
at set this year so if you are
interested in qbf or even if you are
if you are working on a problem that's
related to qbf
please consider submitting a paper so
contact uh
any of the organizers we would be very
much welcome
to host your talk at our workshop we
also have a recurring
uh qbf solver competition qbi freewell
which takes
a break this year but we'll be back next
year
and this solver evaluation and as was
seen with with the sad competition for
instance has been an important driving
force in the development
of qbf solvers
so to give you a brief outline of what
we are
going to present next we are going to
focus on the solving stage in this
abstract workflow
and we are going to give you an overview
of two of the main paradigms
first search-based qbf solving which is
a variant of
cdcl essentially and then in the second
part we will cover
an orthogonal approach which is based on
expansion
and we're also going to consider some of
the theoretical properties and proof
systems that underlie
these systems
so first of all what we are going to do
is we we go back
to the late 90s now so we are in the
year 1998
where this first search based approach
the dpl algorithm for qbf was published
this is on a high level a rather simple
algorithm but it came
already back then it came with quite
sophisticated
improvements which we will analyze in
the
in the following so the pseudocode here
shows a recursive implementation
of vpl for qbf here we are given this
input
a pcnf c and an assignment a
and as a first step what we do and this
is related to
set solving for instance to the
implementation of cdcl we first simplify
the formula under the given assignment a
which gives us a formula
c prime then in the second step we check
whether we hit one of the base cases
where this simplified formula
is actually true or false meaning a
syntactic constant true or false and if
this is the case we terminate
and otherwise we extend the current
assignment
by uh decision making so we pick a
variable from the prefix in that case we
assign
the first variable in that prefix
and branch and then branch recursively
and depending on the quantifier type uh
we have to consider different semantics
here
so if the variable is existentially
quantified we have to find
that um either of the two branches
yields a satisfying result
and for the universal variable we have
to find that
exactly both branches yield a
satisfiable result
so that's a quite straightforward
implementation of qbf semantics actually
um yeah i mentioned um that this is
this is still chronologically
backtracking and one important
improvement that was implemented already
in the first version was
um an improvement of how we generate
assignments so here what we do is only
decision making which is a rather weak
weak way to generate assignments and in
the following we're going to
take a look on how we can improve in
terms of
making assignments
one way to do this is to lift a boolean
constraint propagation which is known
from set solving to qbf
this is what we call qbcp
and this is it's related to bcp as it is
implemented in set solus but it's
it's more general because it it now has
to deal with the universal quantifiers
in the formula
and one particular way to deal with
these variables is by
a technique called universal reduction
you are this is a technique which was
published
in a seminal paper in 1995 by planet
burning kapinski and
fleurgel which we will see also later
when it when it comes to
resolution based techniques for qbf
so um universal reduction takes a clause
and deletes all the letters l
all the universal letters l for which
the existential literals l prime in that
clause
are smaller than the universal literal
with respect to the prefix ordering
so essentially we inspect the clause and
we delete all the universal literals
that are trailing
in the clause so consider
uh for instance this example here uh
universal literals are shown in red for
uh simplicity if we apply universal
reduction to the first clause
then we can see that um we cannot delete
any literal here because
um the universal literal y1
is smaller than the existential literal
x1
so um y1 is not trading so we cannot
delete it here
on the other hand for the second clause
we find that
y2 is trailing and therefore it can be
deleted
so x1 is smaller than y2 and there is no
other existential literal in that clause
which will prevent
the reduction of y2 so we actually can
shorten
that clause here and in the extreme case
for a clause which contains only
universal literals like the last one
here
we can reduce that clause immediately to
the empty clause
showing that the formula is
unsatisfiable
so as you can see this is this is a
powerful technique which
in combination with unit propagation
can bring us closer to to identifying
an unsatisfiable branch in the search
tree
and in terms of theory it was it was
shown that
um universal reduction is
is a technique which can be used to
construct
qbf proof systems so essentially we can
take any propositional proof system
uh adds the universal reduction rule and
the result will be a complete
qbf proof system so this is just um
as a note that this is not just an
implementation technique that we are
using but it's also
a technique that is that is used for
theoretical considerations
universal reduction is part of qbcp
in addition to unit propagation and also
pure literal
detection which we are going to consider
next
unit literal detection is very well
known from set solving
and in the context of qbf it's it works
in
essentially the same way so a given
clause
c is unit if you don't live
it consists of a single literal l which
is uh existentially quantified
given that we can then um set the
variable of
l such that the clause is satisfied so
it's exactly the same
the same as in set solving
uh yeah this is a simple example here
and the given
formula contains the unit clause x2 and
we just
set x2 to true um
by following uh the unit literal
assignment
um qbcp has
a third rule which is pure literal
detection
um this was um i guess also part of
the early dpl algorithm first set but
it's
uh no longer loose used explicitly in
modern set solos because it's it's
deemed to be
um too costly in practice
however for qbf um it was found that is
that it is very effective also
in pruning um uh parts of the search
space
and in particular if we if we consider
unsatisfiable
formulas and formulas which contain lots
of universal variables
so this rule works as follows
we say that the literal l is pure
in a formula if there are clauses which
contain
l positively but no clauses which
contain l
in the other polarity
and if this is the case then we can
[Music]
assign the variable of that pure literal
where the assignment depends on the
quantifier type so if
the literal that is pure is existential
then we assign it in in such a way that
we satisfy all the clauses where it
appears
and if it's universally quantified we
set it in such a way that we um
that we don't satisfy the clauses so
that we actually
shorten all the clauses where that
variable occurs
uh this is illustrated in the example
here
here we have a formula with a universal
variable
y which appears only negatively in the
formula
so what we can do here by the universal
pure literal rule is we can set
y to true and this will uh shorten all
the clauses
where the literal not y appears
um as you can see this is also a
technique in particular for
universal variables which brings us
closer to
identifying unsatisfiable
parts of the search space due to the
shortening of clauses
now to put everything together uh qpcp
boolean constraint propagation for qbf
applies these
three techniques until saturation so we
run universal reduction until there is
no change in the formula we run
unit literal detection and pure literal
detection until there is
no change anymore and we collect all the
assignments
um through through these runs
whenever we find that the formula
reduces to true or false under the
currently identified assignments then we
would immediately terminate
so that's uh as you as you can see an
extension of
bcp for set solving in set solving we
typically only apply
in the basic form unit literal detection
whereas in
uh qbcp for uh qbf we also have
universal reduction and the pure literal
rule uh which which can
or typically do uh influence each other
so
we will see that see this in an example
later on
that um universal reduction due to the
shortening of losses can
um enable additional unit propagations
uh and for instance um this is also true
for pure literary detection
so there is a an influence between these
rules
so let's have a look at an example here
this is a formula where initially no
simplifications by qbcp are possible
so what we do is in order to solve this
formula we first make a decision on
variable
um the first variable in the prefix
which is the universal
y5 here we set this say we set this to
to true and simplify this will
shorten the first clause and make it a
unit
so we can propagate x4
will result in additional
simplifications in particular it will
shorten
the second clause in the formula now
notice that y2 is trailing in this
clause so we can apply
a universal reduction and this produces
a new unit clause x1 but we first
let's say we first propagate uh or apply
uh pure literal detection notice that
the literal not y2 appears only
negatively in the formula but not
positively so we can
set the variable y2 to true
in the next step we propagate the unit
clause x1 that we have identified
and then um we have a formula derived
which contains two complementary unit
clauses so
this immediately shows that the formula
is uh
unsatisfiable because uh the decision
variable that we have
assigned initially was a universal
variable and we have shown
that um this single branch already is
leads to an unsatisfiable subcase so we
are actually done
and we have we have shown that this
formula is unsatisfied with only making
a single decision
so this example shows that qbcp actually
tremendously increases the reasoning
power of
of initial and basic dpl implementations
so in order to integrate dpl
to combine um qbcb with dpl
we actually applied before decision
making so this is a chart which
illustrates
uh the general workflow given the
formula and the assignment a we first
apply qbcp
until saturation this gives us a
simplified formula c
prime then we detect
whether we have hit one of the base
cases if this is not the case
then we assign a variable from the
beginning of the prefix in decision
making
and start over with qbcp otherwise
if we have hit one of the base cases
then we analyze
whether there are open subcases open
branches to be explored if this is not
the case we terminate and otherwise
we backtrack that is um we undo
a subset of the current assignment and
start over with qbcp
so this is the basic dpl workflow
it was extended to from from
chronologically backtracking to
non-chronological backtracking
and in particular it was equipped with
class learning and this
is this is now um what we are going to
look at
next and in particular we are going to
look at um
resolution-proof systems for qbf which
can be can be used
to do class learning uh in in a cdcl
approach
florian can you hear me uh yes so just
uh out of curiosity
uh the this um
like the constraint propagation seems to
be in some sense much more powerful than
in the
in the cdcl setting and we know that in
cdcl it's very important with
these uh you know to watch literal
schemes and other tricks are there like
similar similar nifty implementation
tricks that are very important for qbf
solving or
like anything absolutely absolutely yeah
yeah we also have watched literal uh
techniques uh for pure literal detection
and
and for unilateral detection yeah
okay but that's that's absolutely
crucial for uh for performance in
practice
that is a good a good comment thanks
thanks for that
uh all right so um we now want to equip
this workflow with uh clause learning
and in order to do that we need to have
um
a way to produce clauses and like in a
in a cd cell-based sensor
we do this uh by resolution uh by a
resolution-proof system
and for qbf the first resolution-proof
system was the q resolution calculus
published in
1995 in that seminar paper by kleine
benning karpinski and fleurge
it's an in some sense a lifting of
propositional resolution
to to the qbf setting so let's have a
look um
at the the rules in that system we have
an axiom rule which is called init here
which just tells us that we can um we
can use any clause that appears in the
original formula provided that this
clause is
non-tautological so there is always as
you can see in
in each of these rules there is a site
condition which
tells us that we cannot use any
tautological clauses and the reason for
that is
that we will see that a bit later that
tautological clauses can result in
unsoundness
on the one hand and on the other hand
they can provide additional power so
care has to be taken in terms of
tautological clauses
the second rule is the universal
reduction rule
red here this is exactly the same
as it is used in qbcp it's just
formulated a bit different
so we can give him a clause c where some
some literal l
appears where l is universal we can drop
l
from that clause provided that it is a
trailing
literal in that class so it's exactly
the same as in qbcp
now for resolution as shown on the
bottom here
we have the requirements that the pivot
variable p which appears positively in
one clause and negative in the other
is existentially quantified uh that's
important
and um we are not allowed to produce a
total logical resolvent
uh in the end by applying this rule
so let's have a look at an example
this is a simple formula with two
clauses
initially what we do is we apply
universal reduction
to delete the trailing universal
literals by two from the first and not
by two from the second clause
this produces shortened clauses where
we have a pivot variable x1 and not x1
which we can then use to make a
resolution step
and finally by universal reduction we
get
the empty clause it was shown in
in the original paper from 1995 that
key resolution is refutationally
complete
for uh pc and fs that means
um a pcnf is unsatisfiable if and only
if
we can derive the empty clause by pure
resolution
now recall that we have two important
restrictions
there is the restriction on the
quantifier type of the pivot
which must be existential and we are not
allowed to produce
topological resultants
the completeness holds under these
restrictions
however as we shall see in the following
if we lift these restrictions then we
get
an exponential increase in the power of
the proof system
um at the same um at the same time we
this also increases of course
uh the search space of the proof uh
of how to find the proof because uh now
that we have
when we leave these restrictions we have
more opportunities for making inferences
and this makes it more difficult to find
short proofs
even if they exist
one of these powerful proof systems that
we get from lifting restrictions
is called long distance resolution or
ldq resolution and this is a variant of
key resolution where we are allowed to
produce tautological resolvence
under certain site conditions
uh the axiom rule is not shown here it's
exactly the same
as in q resolution for a long distance
q resolution with a universal reduction
here we have to
um we have to make sure that
um that we uh or we we have to be aware
of that we are now allowed
uh to delete universal literals which
appear complementary in the clause
but these this letter is why star are
called merged literals and this is just
a shorthand for um
an occurrence of a universal little y
and its complement not y so whenever we
see a y star this means
that the given clause is a tautology
essentially
so universal reduction now allows us to
delete these uh merged literals in the
same way as
as the non-merged at the usual universal
literals
under the same um ordering restrictions
so whenever a universal literal whether
it's a merged one or not non-merged one
is trailing we can delete it from the
clause
and for for the resolution rule uh we
now
are allowed to produce tautologies so
for instance
um assume that there is a universal
literal
um l1 uh in one clause and l2 in the in
the second clause
and these literals are um over the same
variable
now if l1 is the complement of l2
um or if either one is merged then the
resolvent would
contain a merged literal meaning that it
is
tautologically and if this happens we
have to make sure
that the pivot variable p is
smaller than the variable which causes
the tautology
so this is a bit involved let's have a
look
at an example this is the same formula
from
uh from before
we can according to the long distance q
resolution rule
select x1 uh variable x1 as a pivot
uh produce a total logical clause and
note that here
uh what happens is we merge uh the
positive literal y2
and the negative literal uh not y2 to
produce a star
literal the merged literal y2 star
and this is possible because y2
is trailing in these clauses first of
all and also
more importantly the pivot is smaller x1
is smaller than
the merged glitter and y2 star that we
produce in the resolution step
and given this clause we can then apply
a universal reduction and derive the
empty clause so this
this is a sound approach it was um it
was shown
in a in a paper from 2012
that this is sound in terms of this
calculus interestingly it was discovered
already
in 2002 in a paper by shang and
malik who realized that
that it is sound to learn totological
clauses in
cdcl although it wasn't formulated as a
calculus
back then
it's important to note that long
distance q resolution is
exponentially stronger than a
traditional q resolution
this means that there are formula
classes for which
a traditional q resolution produces only
exponential size proofs whereas q
resolution long distance q resolution
produces polynomial size proofs
so this was one um one long distance
pure resolution is one
uh powerful proof system we get when we
lift one of the restrictions that is
the totality restriction the other
restriction that we had
in pure resolution was the pivot
quantifier type
we can also lift that restriction so we
just um
drop the requirement that the pivot has
to be existential
that means that we can now resolve on
existential and universal variables in a
similar way
the rest of the rules don't change
actually
the resulting calculus is called qu
resolution
and it's most similar to to what we know
from propositional resolution now
uh interestingly this also results in a
in an exponentially more powerful
system than traditional key resolution
and as a final step we can actually lift
both of these restrictions at the same
time and this
results in a system called lqu
plus resolution so in that system we can
resolve on
existential and universal pivots and we
can produce
tautological resolvence and this is
actually
the most currently the most powerful
known uh
resolution proof system uh here we have
the hierarchy of the resolution based
system that we have just discussed
at the bottom um so if we go from the
bottom to the top
systems become more powerful
exponentially more powerful
we have traditional q resolution at the
bottom
and a solid line indicates
that the system on top is exponentially
more powerful
than the system at the bottom and in
this case for
long distance q resolution and q
resolution it holds that these systems
polynomially simulate q resolution that
means
any q resolution proof is also a valid
qu or long distance q resolution proof
it's interesting to note that long
distance q resolution and q u resolution
are
what we call incomparable that means
that
there are exponential separations
between these systems so
there are formulas which have short
proofs for qu resolution
but exponential proofs for long distance
uh and vice versa so
there's an exponential separation here
and for the most powerful system lqu
plus
um this system simulates both
uh both of long distance q resolution
and queue resolution
and is exponentially stronger
florian yes is there anything
more you can say about these mysterious
merged
literals i mean what what's confusing is
that if i just gave you an original
clause that was
y or not that's clearly tautological and
and
erasing both of these literals would
clearly be unsound right
yes somehow magically when they come
from different clauses
suddenly it's okay to get rid of them i
mean how are
yeah one way to think about this is um
in terms of the
draw functions um when you extract
uh abroad functions from a long distance
q resolution proof
then these these merged literals um give
you
um in some sense an if-then-else chain
uh which tells uh the universal player
how to respond
to the to the moves of the existential
player
but i agree that this is a bit a bit
mysterious
i completely agree
okay thanks
um yeah in the following i'd like to
briefly mention
in the interest of time um some further
extensions
of these proof systems that these
resolution proof systems
which result in potentially
exponential benefits recall that we have
this linear prefix
in a prenux cnf which introduces a total
ordering of the variables
this imposes quite severe restrictions
in in cd cell in terms of how we can
assign
variables and it's also it's also
related
to the universal reduction rule as we
have seen
there is a way to relax these
this this total ordering and this can be
done by
dependency schemes a dependency scheme
is a framework for expressing the
independence of variables
uh essentially it's a binary relation b
over the set of variables
such that if there is given two
variables x and y
if x and y are unrelated in the relation
then we say that y is independent from x
and otherwise if x and y are related
then we say that y depends on x but
that's
a conservative uh a conservative
statement here so the assumption is that
we can compute this dependency relation
d in polynomial time
um which of course is
um is necessary here because um there
are formulas which
um for which this cannot be computed in
polynomial time because otherwise
uh um we would have a polynomial time
algorithm for p space so this is uh in
practice
for many formulas it can be computed
but that's not the general case but the
hope for practical applications is that
we can compute it
in polynomial time and then use it
uh as a refinement of the total ordering
so essentially
in practice this um dependency relation
d
is a refinement of the total ordering uh
resulting in a partial ordering
um of the of the variables
we can use this uh dependency relation
in practice
um to refine the universal reduction
rule
um by just replacing that the total
ordering by the dependency relation
so in order to drop a universal literal
l from a clause
we have to make sure that um that
universal literal
l is unrelated to any existential
literal l
prime in that clause
and there's an interesting body of
related work
that came up where soundness criteria
were proved for different
dependency relations and it was also
shown that this
this more powerful universal reduction
will can be combined with different
resolution-proof systems
one important theoretical result was
that
applying uh this uh more powerful
universal reduction rule
actually gives you an exponential and
exponentially more powerful key
resolution
proof system so this is already the case
for the combination of traditional q
resolution
with um with this dependency aware
reduction rule
in another approach
this was actually brought to the to the
extreme this is called dependency
learning
here we would start temptatively with an
empty dependency relation
then just apply a qcdcl
and whenever it turns out that that we
have we have
missed a dependency we have made for
instance an assignment
which uh broke the dependency relation
that's that's inherent in the formula
then this would be detected by the
failure of producing a learned clause
and in that case we would add the
dependency x and y that was
missed and start over again
so this is a an interesting line of
research which
which gives you additional exponential
improvements
uh for the known q resolution calculus
another approach that that gives an
exponential benefit
is based on exploiting symmetries
um so here we have um a symmetry rule
which we can
add to to any q resolution calculus
and it tells us that from a given clause
c we can derive
the clause sigma c where sigma is a
symmetry
and the symmetry is a bijective mapping
between the sets l and the literals of
the formula
which has certain properties in
particular we have to preserve
the negation of the literals the
application of negations
and we have to make sure that the
literal
x and sigma x the literal where we map
that that x2
appear in the same quantifier block so
it has to respect
uh the total ordering of the quantifier
prefix
and interestingly this is um when we add
the symmetry rule
to q resolution we get an exponentially
stronger system
and it was even shown that if we do this
dynamically so if we
recompute the the symmetry
mapping dynamically under the current
assignment in
for instance the assignment derived by a
qbcp
then this gives additional exponential
gains
also this was this the symmetry rule was
generalized to
homomorphisms and this means
the mapping sigma is no longer required
to be injective
and in that approach also this
quantifier block
restriction was relaxed to some extent
and this again gives exponential
benefits
so to to show you the final picture this
is
an abstract workflow of qcdcl it's very
similar to
what we have seen for qd pll
we have qbcp as an important stage
um we detect whether we hit one of the
base cases if not
there's again decision making but now
clause learning comes in at the stage
where we uh
check whether we have open subcases
and this is very similar to to close
learning in a propositional
set solver however there are due to the
universal variables there are
some some challenges that have to be
overcome in terms of implementation
um in particular
it turns out that in practice only long
distance key resolution
and traditional key resolution was
applied for gloss learning we have
not yet found an efficient way to apply
a qu resolution or this most powerful
lqu plus resolution system that we have
seen
and the reason for that is that like in
a cdcl set solver
the pivots in clause learning are chosen
only from the existential variables by
means of of the variables that became
unit
during qbcp and this naturally uh for
instance prevents
to select universal pivots as would be
necessary for queue resolution
otherwise we have similar concepts like
implication graphs
and asserting clauses in qcdcl
also what we haven't covered here is
um learning from satisfiable
branches in the search tree this is what
we call pube learning a cube is a
conjunction of literals
and whenever we hit
a satisfiable branch in the search tree
we can
essentially learn that branch or a
subset of it
as a cube and add it to the formula so
in
practice the qcdcl solver maintains
a set of original clauses that were
given at the beginning
a set of learned clauses and a set of
learned cubes
now the drawback of course when you
start with cnf is
that um this set of learned cubes
uh grows exponentially in the worst case
for a satisfied
qbf uh and there are um
approaches uh lots of approaches
actually
for a non-cnf uh qbf solving
which uh which can overcome this problem
to some extent
all right to to wrap this part up i'd
like to show you this
uh hierarchy of proof systems once again
um in in gray we have uh the resolution
proof systems that we have seen
um in the second part um martina will
show you
approaches for expansion-based solving
and these these approaches are based on
a proof system called
for all expand plus resolution
as you can see here from this picture
this
this
expansion based approaches are
incomparable they are mutually
separated exponentially separated from
the resolution proof systems
this is true for traditional key
resolution as indicated by this edge
here
but also um also
this is true for the most powerful lqu
plus resolution system
so what we expect from these expansion
based approaches
is actually an orthogonal workflow um
which which in in in some cases could
could exponentially outperform
uh q resolution based uh solving but
this also holds in the other direction
so
there are formulas for which uh
expansion is um
uh provably exponential whereas few
resolution based approaches uh are
polynomial
uh yeah with this i'd like to to
conclude my part uh and if we have time
now i would like it would be happy to
take questions or
also could take questions in the end
whatever is uh is suitable
we certainly do have time for questions
so what usually happens now is that we
have a
a 10 ish minute break but before we take
the break if there are any
questions please feel free to just
unmute
and speak it's also okay to type the
question in the chat and i will try to
read it out
and we can also collect questions in the
chat and
discuss them after the break
uh there was a comment from mata uh is
there also a question related
to this event
i think it was more like a statement
that um i realized that gloria meant it
differently so we don't actually have
too little detection on the what we
would call on the fly
we only have it at what we would call
top level
um and i think what you meant is this um
uh
that that you know you have it uh on the
fly so every decision level
but we actually do have it at the top
level and it's part of what it's
implicitly part of what we call bounded
variable elimination
and it's part of every sub solver that i
know
in the past i see you approximately yeah
yeah thanks a lot i i certainly meant um
that in qbf we do this dynamically at
every decision level
yeah yeah all makes sense yeah
exactly we don't have it everything okay
thanks thanks
so question in the chat uh
from let's see if i can expand to see
the name from tsuhan
is there any work on combining linear
arithmetic with
qbf solving like in smt solvers
um i think in in theory in the in the
field of proof systems there is
but i'm not aware of any practical
implementations
as far as i know well i can i can say
catalin worked with you florian
on on the uninterpreted functions with
you have used york
we have solar actually okay
yeah now you're ready okay
yeah but um i'm not sure whether we
how far did we get with that
well it's described in you know these is
there's one chapter
like but it's like there's no paper so
that's the only thing out there
all right all right
okay any other questions before we
take a break otherwise
uh just christmas yes once more
uh i was curious about you i don't know
maybe
i miss it but you didn't mention or
maybe you didn't go far
mentioning about a certificate of the
proof
i mean you have these all these proof
systems that you described
and i would expect this proof to
i mean what's the strategy when uh when
uh
about uh proof certificates here
especially because of course
there's no difference between uh you
know so this
valid or uh contradictory and so on and
so forth
so can you say something about it um yes
um
we know um for for these systems that
are shown here
that it is possible to extract skolem
and abra functions
from a given proof and this
extraction algorithms are polynomial in
the proof size
although the proofs themselves of course
can be exponential in the in the formula
in the formula size
okay thank you but in the qbf evaluation
like would there be a requirement for
proof logging as in
in the set solving competition or no uh
currently we don't have that and the
reason is
um that we are still lacking a uniform
proof format so ideally we would want to
have something like uh
what d red is in the in this
propositional world
but we don't have that at the moment so
it's possible to use
for instance a generalization of b-red
which is called curette
to produce certificates for satisfiable
formulas
but this is this is still part of
ongoing research to come up with a
uniform format for proofs
okay thank you so then let's take a
break and let's reconvene uh
uh yeah so 17 minutes
to the hour right something like that
okay so we are about to reconvene in
a couple of minutes
if you have any questions thoughts
comments after the first half of the
seminar now is a good time
to use the chat or unmute and speak
yeah thomas sorry yeah no problem um
florian are you there
oh
no he's not uh yes yes hello
hi um my question is
you you mentioned qrad so in the
sat com in the sat solving um
theory rat is is something
that incorporates redundant clauses such
as blocking
block clauses i'm wondering how i think
such a block clause
can occur in qbf
because i could imagine that it could
destroy some
yes some logical consistency i don't
know i don't have any idea
about block clauses think in
qbf redundant clauses in general
yes there is a generalization of blocked
losses
in qbf um and like for propositional
logic
um when you remove or add blocked
clauses um
you don't get an equivalent formula but
only a formula which is satisfiability
equivalent
so it changes the set of models of the
formula
i see oh yeah yeah yeah that's the same
thing in inside
in other higher level redundancy
set block clauses this is under
development i assume
um yes so there is a demo or
spr or something like that um yeah
propagation redundancy hasn't been on
the address
i think okay but there is um
of course red we have a generalization
of red colossus
which is the the curette clauses um this
is this is what we currently have
okay thanks
[Music]
[Music]
okay so uh
martina if you're ready to go
and i think it is uh
time for us to to restart the seminar so
we're switching the speaker
from florian nonsense to to mercenary
the topic is still the same
qbf solving so please thank you jacob
so florman has told us
about the way qbfs can be solved with
cdcl based approaches which come from
the sub world
these techniques we will find there and
yeah this this was already clear in the
early days
that such technology should be
generalized in order also to be applied
for
qbf also in the early days of
qbf solving it was
[Music]
evident where people saw that
there are also different ways of how to
solve
a qbf and this comes quite naturally
from the semantics so here i have the
introduction slide on the semantics of
models and counter models florin
has already showed us and if we have for
example a qbf
which which starts with a universal
quantifier
then uh we have to solve the formula
which we obtain when we replace
this universal formula uh this
universal variable by by two and uh
the we also have to replace this
universal variable by false
and um yeah conjunctively combine
this event and the idea behind expansion
is simply to put this
conjunctively um
this conjunctive combination into the
formula directly
and um this um
would then lead at some end at some
point to a propositional formula which
then
could be handled by that solver and this
i i would like to explain
uh in the rest of this uh tutorial
how this can be done because there are a
lot of technical things that have to be
taken care
of in order to make this work and there
are as foreign already pointed out
um very
important optimization techniques
based on the seeker idea necessary in
order
to to avoid the exponential space blow
up that would come
naturally naturally with with this
expansion
uh yeah but let's let's have a look at
the high level idea so in expansion
based solving the ideas uh successively
eliminate
one kind of variables from a given pc f
or
in in general it can be an arbitrary
structured formula so it's not
necessary that we have a pcnf um
and we do not rely on the clauses here
and yeah in in each
of this step this is the most
naive approach to approach most naive
approach to
proceed with quantifier elimination the
formula is
written and one variable is
somehow eliminated if it's a universal
variable uh then
uh we we have to introduce um a
conjunction of the formal life an
existential variable
we can do it with a disjunction and yeah
if if there are
um quantifiers inside we duplicate
quantifiers and with this
uh we have to be a bit careful and at
some point
um yeah we hopefully have a formula that
contains only one kind of variable so
we have either and purely existentially
quantified variable or a
universally quantified purely
universally quantified
formula and um yeah if it's
existentially quantified then we can
just directly
use a start solver if it's universally
quantified then
we have to negate the formula and can
also use a
solar and see if the formula is valid
problem is um as i already mentioned in
the worst case
um we have an exponential blow up um
if we have n variables of or one kind
then uh the the size so we
we have two to the power of n duplicates
of the formula in the worst case and
this is what is important to be avoided
okay
but before we look at concrete
techniques to avoid this
blow up let's let's have a look at
how how we can do expansion actually
and um yeah in in the
in the approach florian showed us um the
variables were always
processed from the left to the right in
order to
consider the dependencies in the case of
expansion it's actually a good idea to
start
innermost and expand the innermost
variables
first because in expansion uh this
avoids to fabricate quantifiers
yeah and when we have an expansion then
the outermost
variables are anyways shared and
we do not have to introduce new
variables if we start
with with the right most variable and
here
i have an example where the innermost
variables and
exists why it's an existentially
quantified variable
and in one step
we do this expansion
and eliminate y and um yeah
we we have um uh
here the sub formula which we obtain
when we replace y
by uh bottom when we set it to force
and uh then here we have the on the
right we have
some formula which we abstain when we
replace y
by top yeah and the formula we obtain
when we expand this existential variable
uh is not in cnf anymore but this
we have then somehow to convert back
this is something we have to take care
of
maybe um this this we can do with
distributivity or maybe with uh satan
transformation
but here we we have to be really careful
not to
um yeah undo our hard work in
eliminating an existential variable
uh and uh yeah
it's um with this we have to be a bit
um careful and so
this is uh not necessarily the best idea
to do
um yeah but assume we have now the
formula in pc and f
then when we have innermost universal
variable
we can easily or immediately remove it
by
[Music]
universal reduction uh or we could
also uh yeah expand it
and uh yeah then eliminate it
and here in this example this
elimination
then results in a formula which is
already
very trivial to solve yeah this this
would be
a very naive approach in doing
a variable expansion
[Music]
and yeah we have this problem with with
this disjunction uh destroying
the normal form and
this problem we do not have when we
consider universally quantified
variables because then we have to
constructively combine this formula
and therefore an
idea is not to um
eliminate the expand the innermost
existential variable
but to have a look at the universal
variable which is
second innermost in this example and
what we have to do then is um
yeah we duplicate this this quantifier
here
and this is in principle no problem we
then have to
[Music]
rename uh one copy
of the newly introduced variable in
order to distinguish
the two variables and then can
obtain an expanded formula in
cnf where we just have introduced
new existential variables
yeah and
[Music]
this is uh basically uh the
idea behind expansion and if we would
start from the left we would have
would have to be much more careful with
the
renaming of the variables but yeah we
will see that this
is then also an important
property um considered in in modern
uh modern uh expansion-based soldering
and also
in expansion-based proof systems which
characterize expansion-based reasoning
okay um yeah so this this is a general
idea and
some first example is how expansion
works very high level so this is not
now something that's directly
incorporated into a solver
and yeah before i come to modern
expansion-based touring technical
technology i
would like to point out two uh
very old approaches um that uh
so one is the cooper's approach which
was uh presented in 2002
which already followed the idea to
iteratively eliminate one kind of
variable by expansion
um it was heuristically decided which
variable
kind is better to eliminate and uh
then um use um assad solver
yeah coopers did not uh require the
formula
in uh c and f so there wasn't
restriction on the formula structure
which made also the reasoning
a bit more easier and
which also allowed a completely dual
handling
of of the universal and the
existential case yeah and um
so um kubus exactly followed this idea
it eliminated one kind of variables
one kind of variable introduced fresh
variables for those
that had to be duplicated and then
at some point and after hopefully a lot
of optimizations which
could shrink the formula um assad solo
was used to decide
um that the formula uh
the the value of the propositional
formula
and yeah in the end there was only one
sat solva call
um yeah and this this was the basic
behind
the basic idea behind the koopas
approach and
uh which which was back then one uh
quite well working so um
two years later amin birya came up with
the
resolve and expand approach and he
used or he made exactly this observation
we
also did before in the example that uh
the expansion of the innermost universal
variables
does not destroy the cnf structure
and um yeah the prices that we have to
duplicate
the existential variables
behind it and uh in in the quantum
approach
um not only universal expansion was used
to solve the formula this was a
technique to deal with the universal
variables
but um the other
technique that plays an important
role in this approach um is is
the resolve comes from the resolve
approach and
um in order to deal with the innermost
existential variable simply uh davis
batman decision procedure was used and
the existential
variables were eliminated by this
dp approach as it is known from that
um yeah and but this uh senior cnf
structure is preserved and
also then satsura is used to decide uh
the formula at the end and i think years
later
florian did a generalization in his
master thesis
where he again relaxed the requirement
on the cnf structure and
implemented the solar one in effects
okay um this were the origins of
expansion-based qbf solving
um it had this this has uh two
uh branches that it triggers
later on on the one thing this quanta
approach
uh became then the
basis for pre-processing which turned
later
out to be extremely powerful in the
context of qvf
and yeah quanto is for example in the
preprocessor blogger
run not until completion until the
formula is sold but
until a certain limit and this helps
to identify certain information that is
lost through the normal phone
transformation
and when
a certain amount of expansion steps and
this variable elimination steps is
performed and then
the uh the formula that is obtained
by doing these techniques uh can be much
easier solved in many cases
and nowadays uh most
uh solving techniques rely on uh
on this kind of pre-processing
techniques in order
to find uh solutions first yep this was
one stream
of or one branch um of expansion based
solving which
is nowadays still found and the other
thing
is um based in based on
[Music]
seeker which has the idea
or which which is uh based on the
observation that
um yeah expansion is extremely
powerful if the solver doesn't run
out of memory and
in fact it's often enough not to do
the full expansion but only a partial
expansion of the formula so not all
branches have to be considered
um when there are multiple variables and
but it's enough
to consider a certain
amount of expansions and uh yeah for for
uh true qbf a partial existential
expansion
may be enough and for force qbf
the partial universal expansion uh
may be enough and here
the the main insight is that
[Music]
we we could have two um
sub solvers which somehow cooperate in
order
to to solve a formula one takes care of
the existential expansion one takes care
of the universal expansion
and they exchange information in order
to do the refinement yeah and this is
what we have here on this
schematic picture so um
first we start with um with a partial
universal expansion so we do not um
expand all variables fully but only
a part of the formula if the formula is
answered then we can stop because then
the qbf is false if the formula is
satisfiable
we use the model we obtain from the
partial expansion
in order to refine the formula
which gives us the existential expansion
and here we have to do a validity check
if the formula is valid
then we can conclude that the qbf is
true
otherwise we use the information
obtained from from solving
the existential expansion which gives us
counter models
for the original formula in order to
refine the universal expansion and
this we do until at some point define
the solution
and the goal is to find such a partial
expansion quickly
in order to avoid the exponential blow
up in order to avoid
that we have to do the full expansion
and um yeah i first would like to show
you
the approach for two qpfs
a 2qbf is a qbf with a restricted
quantifier
prefix so we have only two quantifier
blocks the first one is
universally quantified so we have the
universal variables mu
and the second block contains
existential variables e and then we have
the propositional matrix which is
quantifier free okay
and having just um
[Music]
a 2qbf makes the situation
much easier and later on i would like to
show you an approach
which allows to generalize the idea to
arbitrary
um arbitrary
qpfs so where we have no restriction on
the number of quantifier recognitions
okay so um this um
expansion uh based sorting approach
first starts with guessing an
assignment of the universal variables
and if we are lucky
and we plug this assignment into the
formula
then the formula the propositional
formula which we obtain
is false
or his answer is fiber so we have only
the existential variables there
and um then we are done
yeah so we we start with the formula
5 with the matrix 5 under the assignment
alpha
and if if the formula
is unsatisfiable then we can conclude
that the formula is false
otherwise we get an assignment
tau to the existential variables
and we use this assignment
tau now uh for
for setting the values of the
existential variables
and this uh we use
um for um refining
um the the existential
abstraction
[Music]
and here we have to solve
a validity problem therefore
we do not put an
or here yeah so we have the first part
of the formula the refinement we
obtained before
uh in principle we would start with with
uh
bottom but we negate it so we start with
top
and then we have the negated or
and uh negated formula in order to check
the validity
yeah and uh if the
formula if this existential expansion we
have
obtained is
unsatisfied
then we can conclude
that the the formula
is um that the original qbf
is true otherwise
uh we we get we get
[Music]
an assignment to the universal variables
which we then
use in the next round in order
to check if
the formula under this assignment is
satisfiable or unsatisfiable and
we proceed like in the first iteration
and
um the nice thing is when we have a two
qbf
um we do not have to
take care about the
the duplication of the existential
quantifier
because all variables which we have here
are then renamed in some sense anyways
in each round
and therefore it's enough to
consider to consider
only one
only one instantiation
of the of the proposition
and um yeah this gives us already a very
nice
algorithm for solving two qbfs where we
have two
sat solvers cooperating in order
to solve a formula so one produces
candidates for models propositional
models
one produces candidates uh for
which are propositional counter models
and
these assemble them to the to the or
ubf model and
this uh approach um was then later on
uh nicolas janata generalized to
arbitrary
uh prefix
prefixed qbf by using a recursive
application of this approach so
where the formula is processed
quantifier clockwise and
it is implemented in the solar rarex
which is now i think
most almost uh
my eyes it's almost
i think it's eight years old also and
uh it's it's still a very good and
efficient solver
although a lot of things have happened
there and this was
really an idea which showed that in in
qbf there are um
alternative ways of a soul of how a
formula
can be solved and that cdcl is not
the only way to go in order to be
efficient with space
and um what i would like
to quickly sketch is a more recent
approach
um which takes up the idea
which uses a non-recursive seeker based
approach so it does not use this
approach
which we have seen before in a recursive
manner
but it uses the idea of
directly annotating the
variables such that
we can build the
[Music]
expansions and instantiations of the
formula
and here the basic idea is that we have
two uh sets of assignments so we collect
the assignments
of the variables and one set contains
the universal variables
the other set contains the set of
existential variables
the set for the assignments of
existential variables is called
s the set of assignments for the
universal variables is called
a and
we use this sets for building
uh the abstractions so these um
what is partial expansions and
these sets give us the parts of the
expanded
formulas um yeah and we have to start
somewhere so
we initialize um a for example with
some arbitrary universal assignment but
um in fact it could also be started with
this doesn't matter
and then um
we proceed with a loop as before and we
will see that the
pseudo code of this approach is very
small it's almost like for a new pbf
we check the partial expansion uh and
uh check if that if it's answered then
the qbf is false
and otherwise uh we update the set s
with um a new assignment which we obtain
for for the existential variables then
we use this assignment for
refining the existential expansion check
if the formula is valid and if yes
qbf is true otherwise we update the set
of assignment
a and what i didn't tell you yet is
how we uh deal with the quantifier
dependencies and
um how we deal with the renaming
and here
the the core concept is to introduce
universal or existential annotations on
this slide i have the universal
annotations and um when we think back
about
this assignment we have seen before then
um for for each quantifier which
we somewhere reach in the tree we know
exactly the path how
we go there how we got there
and this gives us exactly um
a unique annotation for the variable
and this gives us a unique variable
name so assume now we have universal
variables x and your existential
variables y
uh what we do is um we first
define a total order also for the
universal variables with respect to the
prefix because we
have to uh use sequences of universal
variables for
for the annotation and we have to do
this always in the same order
and um yeah we have
an assignment which maps the
the universal variables to some truth
value
and then we obtain
the universal annotation of a formula
by simply assigning the universal
variables according
to the assignment sigma we have seen
before and for the
existential variables we introduce
fresh variables which are now annotated
by uh the the
[Music]
um assignment of the uh
universal variables and for this so we
get a string of
top and bottom and this
exactly reflects the assignment of the
universal variables and with this
we have um we have a very unique
so we have a unique identifier for uh
for each fabricated variable and
we can use this for doing the expansion
yeah here i have an example we have the
formula for a
exists x for all b exists by
and the assignment where a is set to top
and
b is set to bottom and if we have this
clause here then not a
and b the two letters go away x is
annotated
with top because
the only preceding universal variable is
a and a is set to top and y is
annotated with top and bottom because
the two
preceding universal universal variables
are a and b
and they are then
set according to this assignment
and existential annotation works
accordingly
and this is everything that we need in
order uh
to uh have now an expansion based
algorithm for arbitrary variables
and um here we have now the set
um a of uh universal assignments
and the set as of uh
existential assignments we pick an
arbitrary universal assignment in the
beginning
then build the abstraction according
to this formula if the formula is
answered then we return
false otherwise we get a new
assignment to the existential variables
put it into the set s
and then use the set s to build the
other abstraction
check it for validity if it's valid then
we're done
otherwise we refine the set p and so on
and it can be shown
that in each iteration set s and a grow
and at some point we have decided the
formula
yeah and this is uh basically
a non-recursive approach of solving
um solving uh iqbf
uh with this sega based approach and
it's
i think it's it's quite natural
[Music]
by natural implementation of the
semantics of
qbfs here i have an example
which i would like to show you very
quickly due to the
proceeding time i will go very fast over
it
so here we have a qbf which is in uh not
in cnf
because it was more compact to write it
down this way
so here it doesn't matter and we start
with some assignments of the universal
variables
which are a and b so both a and b
are set to force then we get
the annotated formula where we have only
the existential variables that are now
annotated with
the values of a and b respectively and
this is now a purely propositional
formula
and we solve this formula
and this gives us now an assignment to
x and y and
this also gives us now a new
partial expansion now on the variable a
and b
for for example when is that solver
returned us
top and bottom for uh returned us
so uh when the solver returned us top
and bottom
for um
[Music]
for for for the formula we have here uh
we we then get not a and not b
top here it's important that a is the
outermost
universal variable therefore it has no
preceding existential variable
and therefore it has no annotation and b
has only
the x as the notation yeah and with this
we can proceed get
new assignments which we use to refine
the formula
on both sides and at some point
we reached a situation that we cannot
build up a model a qbf model
here we have a counter example and we
cannot
further refine
the formula and therefore we can
conclude that the qbf is force
yeah this is a very quick and short
example yeah and uh this is
also very closely uh related to the
proof system for all expansion
resolution which florian already
mentioned
and yeah i would like to quickly also
introduce this proof system
and also show you how it relates to an
idea i just presented
in the in the fall express proof system
we have two rules
and the first rule is the expansion rule
and the expansion rule exactly
does the the same thing as the
annotation
of the variables as i have shown you
before so it
um it takes a clause c
yeah this is a proof system which now
works on clauses
it takes a clause c from a qbf and
yeah what is important is that the
assignment
that is considered for the universal
variables does not have to make the the
clause
see true so it's important uh
that it's not the settings satisfying
assignment of c
with respect to the universe so this
this
universal assignment is not satisfying
c and uh with this we then get the
annotations of the existential
of the existential literal uh literals
in the clause
and the universal
literals are simply set to force and
then eliminated so um we have one rule
for for
annotating literals and
getting pure propositional clauses and
the second
rule we have is propositional resolution
um
nothing special about this we now have
these annotated variables and
um yeah these these are unique
identifiers and
uh we just resolve or this um
annotated variables
and uh yeah here are an example so in
the first phase
we do this annotation so for example
uh let's take the first clause where we
have x or a
or y um a is um
universally quantified um we have to
we we may only assign it or we
may only use an annotation where a is
force so we get the clause
x or y and annotate it with not a
here i have now written down uh the
literals because it wasn't necessary to
save the space
but here i have not written down the
truth values
but the literal names which is maybe
also easier to read
yeah and this we can do for all clauses
and then we simply can do a resolution
proof
derive a contradiction and decide that
the qbf
is force this is
the basic idea behind the for all
express proof system
this proof um
so if we have this expansion based
approach i just presented we can
we have a solver where we can um
create such proofs for false formulas
and
if we have this proofs proof there have
also been
strategy extraction approaches being
presented
which um yeah i will not
go into details here it's about
assigning values to the existential
variables
uh then
[Music]
rewriting the proof in a certain way and
then
there is only one kind of annotation for
the
outermost universal variables and
this gives the values for the outermost
value variables and then this can be
repeated
until all values are decided
for the universal variables based on the
assignment of the receiving existential
variables
yeah here i would have an example but
due to the proceeding time i will skip
this
and yeah i uh just would like to show
you
uh now the full picture uh of
the proof complexity landscape of the
proof systems based on resolution pure
resolution and
expansion there are also generalizations
of this fall express proof system where
the annotations do not have to be
decided
in the first phase but uh where they can
be done later during the proof so there
is an instantiation rule
and even more generalism uh
in in this m system
annotations can also be merged according
to certain rules and this
gives a lot of power and
gives also a very interesting landscape
in the proof complexity
field for quantified pulling formulas
yeah and with this i come to the
conclusion of this
tutorial um yeah in
to in qbf there are a lot of
opportunities
for new approaches
[Music]
both in theory and in practice and over
the last year
we have seen much progress much
innovation
and i'm pretty sure there's much more to
come and that
there are many more ideas which which
have to be followed
there are also a lot of challenges one
challenge
concerns the tooling so we need robust
and integrated workflows and tool chains
where all comes in one at the moment
it's a bit
distributed we do not have the standards
as in sub
yet because there are still many
questions
open from the fury side and
yeah we have to work more in order to
get a uniform picture
and yeah it would be very nice if we
would have a
universal certification framework as we
would have it in
as we have it in inside in order to to
check the
results and order in also in order
to extract uh scholarly table functions
yeah there are a lot of topics that were
not
covered um in this talk foolproof
complexity nonstop
could be absorbing pre-processing uh on
pre-processing i will give a talk
on next week wednesday's workshop
then there are even more power so very
very powerful
techniques in practice uh based on
clausal abstraction
uh yeah there is um much more theory and
symmetries
dependency qbs and so on so there there
is a lot of
stuff ongoing which could be talked
about
um as a pointer and uh advertisement i
would like
uh to point out that there is a new
chapter co-ordered by
florian all of biased of nicolas yanota
and myself
in the new edition of the handbook of
satisfiability
and a lot of things discussed today and
much more
is covered in this handbook yeah and
with this i would like to conclude
and happy to take questions thank you
thank you martina thank you saurian
okay uploading on behalf of all
uh attendees of this seminar so
uh we certainly do have time for for
questions
yeah really mean one because i would
really like to know the answer
what will be the killer application for
qbf
um so my feeling is that synthesis
has a lot of potential this was also a
very strong driver
in the last years and yeah
i would bet on synthesis
can you say something about how
different techniques
compare i mean also what would a
to the extent that the question makes
sense what would a typical formula look
like i mean is there
um deep levels of nesting of quantifiers
or just
a few levels and are different
techniques of solving
helpful for say shallow or deep formulas
those kind of questions yes
i mean this this is also not entirely
clear but
florian has done a quite extensive study
on this topic
and it turns out that this approach
which
which i just presented is very good on
deep quantifier nestings
the recursive approach prefers
[Music]
less quantifier alternations
but in general it's good to to reduce
the prefix
and and have a few um quantifier
donations
and yeah but but
uh yeah but what what one can say is
that
these this technique which i
showed works pretty well on
many quantifier isolations so this is
beneficial for this approach
so i thought i've got a quick question
about uh
kind of related to that quantify
alternation just mentioned
so inter you introduce the the cigar
based algorithm also the non-recursive
one
and i mentioned that there's a um
generalization of that
that means using that approach we can
deal with different form
of the alternation because in the in the
example we see for for all exist
it it it can be by by using that
expansion but
if if it is in other form can you still
do that i'm not
sure about the question but what do you
mean this other form
like if we have starting from exist
and then you do the expansion
it's completely independent of the of
the quantifier structure so
this this can can be done for arbitrary
quantifier
and arbitrary quantifiers and um i i
just
started with the 2qbf approach because
um in fact this this approach is it's
very simple but
writing it up concisely is very
technical and this you
don't have to do qpf approach because
there you have less uh dependencies uh
to be considered
and and you you um
yeah it's easier to write up but in
general both
that the recursive approach and the
non-recursive approach
um can be applied to arbitrary prefix
structures would that affect
complexities a lot uh to to what
uh uh complexity i was thinking about
for different uh complexity
like for if we want to tackle all those
expansion
so assume you mean from from uh run
times or from from theory
from theory
yeah i mean there is definitely some
some connection
but i don't have any details on that
okay thank you
um i actually have one question
i'm curious what do you think
how could we um how could we use the
some of these techniques within sat as
you know there's been
quite a lot of interesting work that
lately has been
put into um effectively borrowing
ideas from other areas for example
um local search solving and
sort of shoving it into ctcl solvers
and also combining for example
um a look ahead search with um
with cdcl search um
and so there's been and and i mean i
personally am of course have been
working on some of this and i know that
also
others have been working on some pseudo
bullying so there are some
interesting um work that effectively
tries to combine
uh ideas from other areas and shoving it
back into saat
and see because of course you have also
your your um
area seems to have been partially at
least informed
and perhaps also in inspired by some of
the work that has been done
you know on south and and and i think
this could be sort of like this virtual
cycle where
you know some of the work that is here
is inspired or informed by
the work from the south community and
and then some of this can be sort of
cycled back
and and the work that you have done you
know can be used within the south
community
so what what are your ideas and what do
you think would be like
interesting avenues to um to to sort of
take ideas from
here and show it back into some yeah one
thing i i could think of is that there
are
maybe some pre-processing techniques
which which are beyond np
and which would help to to get
information out of the propositional
formula that
could maybe help the the sat solver to
find the solution faster
so if there is a certain part of a
problem
extracted and then maybe some
expensive qbf expressible
pre-processing technique maybe it's used
and this this could then maybe help to
guide the subscriber for for
search i could imagine that's also to
use use qbf maybe as a preprocessor for
some brain processor for some expensive
techniques
this would one thing that comes to my
mind
yeah pre-processing is effectively what
has been happening so
you know for example the locus resolvers
have been used as form
effectively top level processors you can
call them preprocessors in processors
whatever you like but
actually and interestingly the latest um
the one that won second place last year
was doing it
in the middle of the search at the
middle of the search tree which was
very strange to me but i know that army
and myself both use so the first and
third place both use
um um a top level
local search solvers um as effectively
preprocessors or in processors to inform
the search
in this case the the parity and the
default parity of the
of the variable but okay that's i mean
that's interesting yeah thank you
are there further questions
otherwise i just want to take the
opportunity also to mention that all
registered workshop participants should
be able to login
in gather town at the simons institute
workshop space
so i put the link in the chat now again
this might also be a further opportunity
to continue the discussions
and if there are any questions now is a
good time to ask but i don't
see anything in the chat i think
so i think
that we'll just thank uh martina and
florian again
um thank you so much for a wonderful
seminar and for those
of us who can make it the simon's
workshop gather town space is waiting
thank you so much